[Music]
gratulations on on all your success Amin
you have this one guest spot and so many
actors in this town get a quick guest
spot and then that's it and this turns
into a regular part on this powerful
series now your family must be very
proud I match oh my goodness they're
beyond thrilled my parents actually came
out to a taping really they were so
excited they're sitting in the audience
and you know they play music in between
scenes yes so my parents are dancing I
saw my dad like bite his lip at one
point do a little shimmy I've never seen
them more excited in my life and at one
point some of the cast members went up
to them to say hi are you having a good
time and I saw my mom get so excited and
kind of I thought she was gonna pass out
were you embarrassed or you're okay with
this I'm kind of worried for her help
yet otherwise I was good and then she
came backstage after and they're from
the East Coast and I wasn't sure if it
was her thinking that in Hollywood she
had to morph into something else but all
of a sudden every time I introduced her
to someone she became a star from the
40s I was like it's a pleasure
[Laughter]